خطوه وتخطيط ومحاولات اغتيال انشطه لا
يمكن عنوانتها الى تحت مظله تنظيمات
ارهابيه
في نوفمبر الماضي والتي كانت محاوله
اغتيال لرجل اعمال اسرائيلي في ارضها يكشف
الستار اليوم عن منافذها ايران
انترناشونال في تقرير حصري نشرت اسماء
والصور المتهمين بتنفيذ المحاوله حامد عبد
الله محمد رضا
ليس مواطنين ايرانيين عاديين بل العناصر
في فرق القدس التابعي للحرس الثوري
الايراني وتحديدا في الوحده 4
مخطط صممه الفيلقو ليدير العمليه في عده
دول ويستعين بفريق ان يرتبط بالقاعده لجمع
المعلومات
كانت بقياده حسين رهبان الذي تشير
المعلومات الى تلقيه التعليمات مباشره من
اللواء حمد عبد الله وهو قائد وحده فيلق
القدس 400 والذي كان نائب قاسم سليماني
يتزمن التقرير الذي نشرته ايران انترنال
مع طرح اوروبي لوضع الحرس الثوري على
قائمه المنظمات الارهابيه
قد يضم عددا من دول الاتحاد في اطار
السياسه الامنيه خاصه
جاء على خلفيه اعدام عدد من المتظاهرين في
الحراك الشعبي الحالي في ايران الى ان
محاولات الاختيار المنظمه قد تزيد امكانيه
التحول مشروع الى قرار فعلي استنادا
للقوانين والاعراف الدوليه
ايفا عمر العربيه